des tableaux aux couleurs aussi vif que
leur message
il ne s'agit pas de toile mais
d'impression sur plaque alu mignonne
khroma luxe dessinée à l'ordinateur en
octobre 2014 alors que je n'avais jamais
ni pain ni dessinée ni quoi que ce soit
du genre je me suis mis à faire lors
d'une fête de famille des dessins et des
peintures sur des tablettes et mon beau
père qui est peintre assez dur à un
moment donné ma ma vue faire il m'a dit
pas mal tu es merde alors j'ai continué
l'exposition est en deux parties suivant
ces deux techniques de création après
l'impression l'oeuvre poste digitales
des oeuvres conçues en numérique
réinterpréter à l'acrylique sur toile
je voulais absolument remettre de
l'humain dans le digital
alors c'est doublement paradoxale par
rapport au fait des artistes numériques
mais bon je trouve ça vraiment
importante les gens se posent la
question
une réflexion sur la place du numérique
dans notre époque et sur l'identité on
retrouve régulièrement sur ses oeuvres
un même personnage
le boat idoc le canard au noeud papillon
ce que je veux montrer c'est que un seul
ce canard qui n'est rien qui n'a pas
dieu qui n'a pas de bouche tout le monde
peut se projeter dedans et donc c'est
votre identité propre en tant que
spectateur qui peut émerger il ya 7
milliards d'identité pour l'instant est
sage de l'ani pas évidemment que chacun
on a notre propre identité
par contre on peut pas dire et je pense
c'est vraiment une illusion qui a une
identité de groupe à part celle des
êtres humains
ces deux dernières années de travail de
l'artiste exposé réfléchissent la
lumière avec leurs couleurs pour que
celle ci pousse votre propre réflexion